the British government has updated its
list of warning signs of political
radicalization to include reading books
by C.S Lewis
J.R.R Tolkien George Orwell Joseph
Conrad and Aldous Huxley
Narnia Lord of the Rings 1984 Heart of
Darkness Brave New World if you are a
Brit who reads the classic novelists of
the 20th century novelists who
specifically focused on Christianity and
the threats of totalitarianism and
dystopia
the current dystopian totalitarian
government considers you a potential
terrorist there's a non-fiction list too
according to the spectator other authors
whose work resonates with the radical
far right include Thomas Hobbes John
Locke
Edmund Burke Thomas Carlisle Adam Smith
and
Shakespeare
guess there's some non-fictions mostly
fiction but he wrote the histories too
didn't he in other words if you are
in any way cultured if you have read any
political work any 20th century literary
work any of that that really matters at
all even if all you've read is John
Locke the father of liberalism You Are
by today's standards a radical
right-winger which
when you think about it is probably true
and it's not the only part that's true
the British government is keeping an eye
on people who read those books because
the government fears that those books
undermine the current regime in Britain
certainly but let's say throughout the
anglosphere really throughout the whole
West and we laugh and we Mock and we
call the Liberals paranoiding crazy
but on that point too on the threat from
these classic Works to our current forms
of government
the liberal regime is Right a Michael
Knowles is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of the
Brits coming up we've got Elon Musk
giving a master class in how to handle
the liberal media especially in this
case the BBC we'll get to that in just a
little bit first though conservatives
don't take this stuff seriously enough
we laugh at the libs we mock them we
call them snowflakes we talk about how
crazy it is we talk about the double
standards we say all these wacky lips
can you believe they want to ban CS
Lewis right why do they want to ban C.S
Lewis because they say that reading C.S
Lewis is a sign that you are politically
radicalized against the current regime
which is true we live under regimes that
are extremely hostile to Christianity
that are increasingly totalitarian that
are sending us hurtling into dystopian
societies we're living under regimes
that celebrate the killing here in the
United States celebrate the killing of
800 000 babies per year and which
completely redefine marriage and which
dissolve like an acid being poured onto
the structures of society dissolve the
basic political institutions and which
now chop off the body parts of children
which now castrate children and pretend
men can be women and women can become
men
yeah reading C.S Lewis and Tolkien and
the great writers of our civilization is
going to pose a threat to that regime
because reading those authors is going
to remind people of the truth and it's
going to shine a light on the lies that
were being told by the regimes we're
living under this is a threat the libs
are wrong about pretty much everything
that's the topic of my speech coming up
tonight at the University of Wisconsin
Superior
they're wrong about pretty much
everything
but they're pretty good at politics
the one thing they're not wrong at is
political tactics to wield political
power
you can expect these sorts of lists here
in the United States
conservatives we point out how crazy it
is that we've kicked the Bible out of
schools and we've inserted gay porn into
schools
yeah it's bad for kids education but
it's not just a wacky weird accident
that the libs did that the libs did that
for a purpose which is to advance their
agenda and wield political power and
it's worked out pretty well for them now
speaking of the Brits President Biden
just
uh just arrived he is on a Tarmac he
gets off an airplane at the bottom of
the tarmac is the prime minister of the
United Kingdom Rishi sunac and the
interaction between Biden and sunac just
absolutely chef's kiss perfect
Joseph R Biden the 46th president of the
United States making his way down the
steps to be greeted five in walking down
the steps okay Shake sunak's hand then
immediately pushes him to the side
and starts talking to someone else
and then speaks for a much longer time
to this other guy who
seems like a kind of interesting guy
he's got a kind of a funny hat on but is
probably not as important a political
figure in the UK as Rishi sunak
what are the odds that Joe Biden knew
who Rishi soon Act was in this situation
zero nothing
hey ah yeah hey what's going on there
get out of my way Jack I got to talk to
cool hat guy hey I like that hat Jack
you want to scratch my legs kiddo let's
go let's get some ice cream come on huh
what are the odds I'm not joking about
it I don't I am not convinced that Joe
Biden knew who the prime minister of the
United Kingdom was in that clip
I don't really like Rishi sunak so I
think it's kind of funny that President
Biden was rude to him
Rishi sunak is kind of a big lib
but
it's less funny when you consider that
this is the man who is supposedly
leading the Free World Biden not sunak
and when you consider that we're on the
brink potentially of World War III I
don't throw
those words around all that lightly I
know there are many conservatives who
are always catastrophizing about how the
nuclear bombs are about to start flying
we are closer to World War III now than
we've been any time since the Cuban
Missile Crisis certainly and probably
anytime since World War II a genuine
World War because you've got the first
major war in Europe breaking out because
Joe Biden screwed up foreign policy in
Ukraine and then because you've got a
potential war in the Pacific breaking
out because Joe Biden is screwing up
foreign policy over Taiwan
so and it's not just Biden's fault
liberals in the foreign policy
establishment have completely mishandled
both of those issues for years if not
decades at this point
but Personnel does matter Personnel is
policy as they say in Washington
and that Personnel includes the
president of the United States and if
you've got a president who doesn't know
who world leaders are who is bungling
foreign policy just as he's bungling
this interaction with the leader of
Great Britain that is not a good
situation for us to be in one good thing
we could do on this subject and just
broadly is to pray a lot more that's why
you got to check out hallow right now go
to hallow.com Knowles building a habit
of prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the United
States it's helped all of us to maintain
a daily prayer routine and it can help
you too download the app for free at
hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way not sure
where to start using hallow to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
with hello you can customize a personal
prayer plan that that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions download
Hello at hello.com Knowles get an
exclusive three months free which will
carry you right through this Easter
season that is three months absolutely
free at hallow.com Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s do not put it off any
longer you are being made in the image
and likeness of God you owe God prayer
hello.com Knowles
president Trump the leader of the
opposition who for now is not wearing an
orange jumpsuit he's come out and he
said he doesn't see how this Joe Biden
could possibly run for president in
2024. do you think Biden will stay in
the race
look uh I I watch him just like you do
and I think it's
almost inappropriate for me to say it I
don't see how it's possible but there's
something wrong
I saw his answer today
on television about whether or not he
was going to run to a very nice guy
named Al Roker
when you can't get us off to a question
then that that was a long answer
talking about the eggs and this and that
look
I don't think he can
I don't think that this is President
Trump simply performing care you know
concern trolling over Joe Biden's Health
one of the delightful aspects of trump
which is also one of his weaknesses so
many of his strengths are his weaknesses
is that he's unvarnished he just says
what he thinks and he he speaks in an
almost stream of Consciousness and
that's what you see here I think this is
sincere he says look it's kind of kind
of inappropriate for me to say I don't
think he can something is very wrong
with this guy it's not just a cheap
political attack that's not the kind of
rhetoric that has been Focus tested he's
just saying what we're all thinking in
fact not only is one of Trump's great
strengths and weaknesses his own stream
of Consciousness what really makes it a
strength is that especially in the 2016
campaign he was our stream of
Consciousness too he was just the sort
of unvarnished ID of the American people
saying the things that we all know to be
true that that no one had been allowed
to say in politics for a long time up
until that point
but but I don't think Trump is right on
the point here in Trump says how can he
run for president I think it's very
simple how he can run for president
they just sit him in his chair in his
living room
and the liberal establishment goes to
work in exactly the same way that it did
in 2020.
in 2020 Joe Biden pretty much did not
campaign he would have a dozen two dozen
people at his campaign events on the
rare occasions he would have them the
rest of the time he sat on his front
porch and the liberal media did the work
for him
it was a little easier in 2020 because
the Liberals had the covet excuse to to
justify why Biden wasn't wasn't
campaigning
but now they just won't have him
campaign
we're in a moment of such transparent
partisanship that I'm not sure it really
matters
plus with all the changes to the
election system I'm not totally
convinced that
if Joe Biden was anywhere even closer
within Striking Distance that the
Democrats would not be able to make the
numbers work and then sit on the ballot
box to to quote Franklin Roosevelt
giving advice on how to steal elections
to one of his mentees Lyndon Baines
Johnson this is explained in the Robert
Carroll biography of LBJ I'm not
convinced there there have always been
extra measures that the liberal
establishment can use to take elections
and I'm I'm
not convinced that Joe Biden who doesn't
know what what his name is Joe Biden who
doesn't know which end is up Joe Biden
who who doesn't understand who the prime
minister of the United Kingdom is on a
trip to the UK I'm not convinced
that that guy can't run for president
without running at all now there are new
candidates in the race
every day it seems there are new
candidates running for president
especially in the Republican field I am
and I've maintained this from the
beginning I am going to be the only
Republican left in America who will not
be running for president in 2024. the
reason for that of course is that I will
be constitutionally ineligible although
these days the Constitution doesn't seem
to limit a lot of political action a
great thing about that is I guess I'll
be the only person eligible to moderate
the debates because I'll be the only
Republican not on the stage so drumroll
please who is our new candidate in the
race
Senator Tim Scott
on this day April 12 1861
in this Harbor the first shots of the
Civil War were fired and our country
faced the defining moment
we truly be
one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all Joe Biden and the
radical left have chosen a culture of
grievance over greatness they're
promoting victimhood instead of personal
responsibility and they're
indoctrinating our children to believe
we live in an evil country and all too
often when they get called out for their
failures they weaponize race to divide
us to hold on to their power when I
fought back against their liberal agenda
they called me a prop a token because I
disrupt their narrative I threaten their
control they know the truth of my life
disproves their lives
see I was raised by a single mother in
poverty the spoons in our apartment were
plastic not silver
the ad goes on it goes on for three
minutes and after the biographical
features Senator Scott gets to his issue
positions which are pretty standard
Republican issue positions
the ad opens up leaning on Race as you
just saw so that's the the opening pitch
two voters is
the Liberals hate me especially because
I'm a black guy and as you all know
black conservatives are one of the most
detested groups by the liberal
establishment look what they do to
Clarence Thomas look what they do to
Candace Owens they do the same thing to
me and I
by virtue of being a black conservative
disrupt the liberal narratives so that's
one advantage that I Tim Scott have over
the other people in the race Nikki Haley
had a similar message at her laid out in
that declaration video Nikki said I I'm
I'm a woman I'm a strong woman this is
unusual the libs don't really like that
and when I'm taking names and kicking
people in the teeth it's going to be a
lot better when I'm wearing high heels
that was the pitch then
Senator Scott goes on and issues this
opening Salvo to say that I'm I'm
forming an exploratory committee which
is the first step to start running
it's a well-produced ad it's not that
Tim Scott is
has not prepared for this he has and
we've known that Senator Scott is going
to run for president ever since his
publisher
leaked that information at this point
what a year ago at least six months ago
it was and then at that time Senator
Scott's office came out and said no
we're not we don't have any plans to run
for president why did you stupid
publisher leak this information now and
but but we all knew that he was going to
run when people when politicians put
books out during an election cycle it
means almost all the time not 100 of the
time but almost all the time that
they're going to run for president
the problem with the ad is it just feels
dated
this feels to me like a 2012 AD
and it feels to me if this is all we
know about the campaign like a 2012
Campaign which is you're starting to get
slicker
more highly produced media but it's not
it's just it's like a TV ad
but we don't live in the era of TV
anymore we live in not even the era of
social media at this point we live in
the hyper reality of the metaverse we
live in in even shorter punchier content
we're not in the age of YouTube really
anymore I mean we are right here in the
sense that many of you are watching this
on YouTube but we're in the age of
YouTube shorts
right we're not in the age of Facebook
we're in the age of Instagram video
where everything's really tight and cut
and fresh and Trump was both a symptom
of this and one of the causes of it one
of the motivators were Trump blew open
the traditional script on politics Trump
ran a campaign that was in many ways a
meta campaign it was a political
campaign about political campaigns you
remember in 2016 Trump comes out and he
says look I know I'm not I don't sound
really presidential what am I supposed
to do I'm supposed to put on my necktie
and I'm supposed to say boom in this bed
I'm not going to do any of that you know
and that was very refreshing
it's very difficult then in in the
post-trump age when Trump himself is
still running for president to go back
to the old script that that he was
making fun of you saw this with Chris
Christie and Marco Rubio in the 2016
race when Marco Rubio made some Focus
tested comment and Chris Christie said
you know this is the worst part of these
politicians who give the 30-second
canned response that they've had a team
of Consultants right up and Rubio
felt called out as he was and so Rubio
tried to respond to Christy but he
couldn't do it extemporaneously he
couldn't do it off the cuff so he he
just went back to the very same 30
second canned response that he had
previously said that led Christy to make
fun of him and so Christy totally
pounced on him and said there it is
there's that line and from that moment
Rubio looked
like yesterday's news he looked like a
stale old candidate and it it ruined his
campaign
so can Tim Scott break himself out of
that I don't know I think he's a really
nice guy I like Tim Scott a lot he's
been on I don't know I guess he hasn't
been on this show he has been on verdict
with Senator Cruz when I hosted that
show and so
he'll have a role in the race but
if he doesn't figure out a way to make
the race about
2024 rather than
about a typical political ad in
political messaging I'm not sure he'll
go very far now
campaigns are not dead yet the campaigns
are just getting started but you will be
dead and sooner than you think which is
why you got to check out epic will right
now go to epicwill.com use promo code
Knowles there are certain things in life
that you do to protect your family you
get life insurance you save for a rainy
day fund and you write a will epic will
is not for people who are already
wealthy with a massive estate those
people need an attorney epic will is for
people who are building their estate and
building their wealth it is for people
who are just getting started epic will
provides a simple and secure platform to
create a legally binding will in minutes
with their user-friendly interface you
can easily customize your will and
ensure that your assets are distributed
according to your wishes unlike
traditional law firms that charge High
fees for will drafting epic Will
services are affordable and transparent
no hidden costs through surprises all
you need to do is fill out their
step-by-step form they will help you
create your last Rule and testament
living will health care and financial
power of attorney in as little as as
five minutes and for just a hundred and
nineteen bucks do not
put this off any longer make sure that
your stuff and your money and your kids
especially are taken care of when you
die which will happen sooner than you
think go to epicwill.com
use promo code Noel scanner wlas to save
10 on Epic Will's complete will package
that is epicwill.com promo code Knowles
the wait is over the yes or no pre-order
is complete games are shipping now you
can order right now at dailywire.com
shop games are going quickly and
supplies will not last the last time we
did this we sold out instantly we are a
little bit worried that we cannot make
these fast enough so we're not going to
just sell infinite numbers right now we
are selling what we've got
order now to secure your copy then we'll
have to do another pre-order when these
all sell out now it's not the time to
back out unlike a certain purveyor of
trans ideology this is something you do
not want to miss out on order yes or no
the game only available at
dailywired.com slash shop
we have another candidate in the race
that's right if you're not feeling Tim
Scott mentum well that's okay there's
another candidate who's going to fill in
more of the clubbable moderate land in
the race you know who that is
Mitt Romney
speaking of 2012
campaigns speaking of deja vu all over
again
Senator Mitt Romney
took his first step toward launching
a re-election campaign
by submitting a declaration of candidacy
to the Federal Election Commission but
the Utah senator stopped short of
confirming that he would run for another
term so this is Mitt Romney saying okay
I'm maybe going to run for re-election
as senator in Utah
but is leaving that open now the
question is
will Romney run for president in 2024.
he just keep saying I'm keeping my
options open
oh I don't know what I'm going to do I
just want to start being able to raise
money we'll see how things go Romney has
been pretty coy about his future plans
and he's right to be kind of coy
because everybody I mean everybody is
going to run for president in 2024.
and so when Romney says I don't know am
I going to run for Senate am I not going
to run for Senate what am I going to do
maybe I'll retire maybe well we'll just
see we'll reevaluate the field
he is keeping that option open if he did
choose to run for president in 2024 this
would be very bad news for candidates
like Nikki Haley for candidates like Tim
Scott who are running more in the
moderate Lane I'm not saying Mitt Romney
would get the Republican nomination that
would be hard to imagine
but
we are in Uncharted Territory
so everyone who thinks Trump's got this
totally locked up everyone who thinks
Trump is toast and DeSantis has this
totally locked up everyone and this
seems like almost all Republicans now
who think well it's going to be one of
those two guys
we are in Uncharted Territory folks the
libs are arresting the leader of the
opposition
we're we're going to have a field of
about a bazillion candidates
even
rum numentum momentum is not Unthinkable
now speaking of management Consultants
Anheuser-Busch
has lost over six and a half billion
dollars of market cap
after their Embrace of Dylan Mulvaney
and trans ideology
the shares of Anheuser-Busch inbev
dropped nearly five percent after
Mulvaney announced that Bud Light deal
wiping out 6.65 billion dollars of
market capitalization
before the conservative starts
celebrating remember this might just be
temporary
okay boycotts are really really hard
especially against big established
companies with a zillion Brands like
Anheuser-Busch because you need to
pursue them over the Long Haul
when conservatives can focus their fire
on one company in particular that maybe
is not the largest company and you can
maintain that over a long period of time
like for instance the conservative
revolt against Harry's Razors that led
to the creation of the finest razor
product in the world Jeremy's razors
when you can do that the boycotts can be
effective but when you're just angry
about a video with a transvestite from
your beer company
you might stop buying the beer for a
week or two but eventually very often
the companies will be able to survive
that however in this case
Anheuser-Busch is clearly worried
because we've got new headlines today
that the Bud Light leadership did not
know about this this was done behind
their backs by lower level people in
marketing and they're investigating
everything right now
according to Anonymous sources in the
media no one at the senior level of the
company was aware of Bud light's
polarizing partnership with Mulvaney the
company is looking into pausing those
marketing efforts they're trying to
implement a more robust process for
evaluating future influencer
Partnerships
that to me that anonymous source to the
journals that doesn't read like an like
someone just leaking information from
the boardroom what that reads to me
is
a crisis Consulting team was brought in
to Bud Light to figure out what the hell
to do about this because the backlash
against Dylan Mulvaney was far greater
than Bud Light expected but I don't buy
this stuff for a second no one at the
senior level knew about this give me a
break
this contradicts what Bud Light had
previously said
Bud Light had already issued a statement
defending the Mulvaney sponsorship
decision
the the VP of marketing at Bud Light had
had on video touted her mandate to make
the brand more inclusive but even okay
let's say she's a rogue VP at the
company
the company itself issued a statement
the company issued a statement
confirming the partnership with Mulvaney
and describing it as an attempt to quote
authentically connect with audiences
across various demographics and passion
points
and that didn't play the initial
sponsorship didn't play very well
certainly among a lot of Bud light's
audience then the doubling down on it
didn't play very well and so I'm sure
they've just brought in a crisis
Consulting team to say okay here's how
you've got to back away from this and
it's it's brilliantly done by whichever
crisis consultant communications
consultant wrote this up because Bud
Light if if Bud Light doubles down as
they did with their statement on the
Mulvaney partnership then they alienate
their core base of Frat Boys and
construction workers and regular dudes
who like to drink a domestic beer at the
bar
but if Bud Light runs away from Mulvaney
they'll irritate the liberal mob
which does not represent the Bud Light
customer base but which wields all the
political power in the country so then
Bud Light could be canceled for that and
they'll find themselves in a worse mire
than they were before so what do they do
they they create what I am convinced is
a false conflict between the senior
leadership and the people at the lower
level and they say they're looking into
this and they're investigating this so
they get credit among the conservatives
for saying yeah this is crazy we we
agree with you conservatives but they
don't arouse the ire of the Liberals
because they portray this as well the
young the young people at Anheuser-Busch
are turning this thing around and they
support trans rights and just hold on a
little longer and those Senior People
they'll have aged out of the company and
there there will be this is classic
crisis communications consultant
gobbledygook from a company that is
scrambling to make sense of a very bad
decision but a company that has not
learned a damn thing about why people
are a little miffed
that that Bud Light is using a basic
beer for normal people to shove this
insane transgender ideology down our
throats now speaking of sex stuff
there is some great news we always talk
about really bad news when it comes to
weird sex stuff in America because the
libs are using sex
all the time to push their radical
agenda but here's some great news
000 Americans are alive today
because of the courage and Clarity legal
and moral Clarity of
Supreme Court justices in the Dobbs
decision 32
000 fewer abortions
took place in the six months after the
Dobbs decision
this according to a left-wing nonprofit
the Society of Family Planning that
believes in abortion that totally
supports the infant decide abortion the
report from them or the abortion
infanticide rather the report found that
there were an average of 5377 fewer
abortions in the U.S each month in the
six months following Dobbs there has
been a decrease in the abortion rate not
to zero as the Liberals warned would
happen and as should be the case but the
dip was from 13.2 abortions per 1000
women of reproductive age
per month to 12.3 so it's just it's a
dip
not nearly as deep as one would like but
it's a dip it's significant in every
every one of these Americans who is
saved from murder in the womb
is a cause for national celebration
saving just one of these people
convincing just one one woman not to
have an abortion allowing just one
person to have life that great gift of
life that you cherish so much that is a
greater achievement than
everything most of us will do in our
entire lives
just one for if you can pray outside of
an abortion clinic and you can persuade
one woman not to kill her kid and that
kid gets to have a life
that is a greater achievement than most
of us will achieve in our entire lives
and there are 32 000 people just within
the six months
after after the Dobb's decision who will
have that gift 32 000 of those great
achievements
basically a miracle in a country such as
ours that's really something worth
celebrating
another thing worth celebrating getting
your propane tank swapped out easily
it's why you got to check out cinch
right now head on over to cinch.com use
promo code Knolls it's starting to get a
little bit warmer over there in
Tennessee friends and neighbors are
already breaking out the old barbecues
taking the grill pill the last thing you
want to be doing when you're getting
ready for the weekend cookout is driving
around trying to find a place to refill
your propane grill tank that's why you
need cinch cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule no long-term
commitment or subscription is required
you can do it just as a one-off when you
need Propane Plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to be home to
receive the delivery you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere go
online to cinch.com
c-ynch.com or download their app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knolls Canada wlas go to
cinch Dot Com or download the Cinch app
and use promo code Knowles
Knowles to get your first tank exchange
for just ten dollars see why nch.com
promo code Knowles limited time offer
you must live with an essential service
area to redeem it visit cinch.com offer
for details my favorite comment
yesterday is from Katie Jacobs who says
can't wait to see you tomorrow I go to
uws University of Wisconsin Superior and
had no idea about this event they
suppressed information when Matt Walsh
came to the campus too many such cases
I've heard this this semester because
the libs are so furious at me for saying
the boys and girls are different
people have generally known when I'm on
campus Because the libs and antifa and
the trans activists have not stopped
screaming about it since the events were
announced but sometimes what they do is
they'll pull down the Flyers and they'll
they will keep a lid on these things
where they'll go in and they'll Reserve
all the tickets for the event
so that they can either not show up or
they can stage a walk out when they do
show up and the people who want to get
into the event some people who have
traveled a great Distance by car some
people even fly in for these things
won't be able to go see the event so I
would recommend tonight if you haven't
been able to get a ticket if it says
it's sold out
and you've got some free time maybe try
to show up wait in the standby line see
if you can get in it should be a lot of
fun I'll be flying out
very shortly after this show okay
speaking of lies from the liberal
establishment
Elon Musk has just offered an absolute
master class in how to handle
the powerful establishment lives and he
did so in an interview with the BBC
I just want to go Moment by moment to
enjoy this delectable lesson
in rhetoric it would describe a hateful
thing yeah I mean you know this content
that will solicit a reaction something
that may include something that is
slightly racist or slightly sexist those
kinds of those kinds of things so you
think if something is slightly sexist it
should be banned
so the the conversation begins with
with the accusation that under Elon
musk's pro-free speech or more Pro Free
Speech Twitter Reign there's more
hateful content on the site that's the
meme that's the talking point from the
liberal establishment so how does Elon
begin he doesn't say how dare you I
didn't do that that's a lie and X Y and
Z here are the reasons why that he says
what's an example
give me just one example of the thing
that you're talking about or give me a
more precise description
and the BBC journalist says well you
know
I have something sort of slightly racist
or sexist and so then Elon takes the
Free Speech approach he says you're
telling me if something is slightly
sexist he doesn't focus on Race because
being called a racist is the worst thing
you can be called in our culture we
focuses on sex he says something is
slightly sexist
whatever that means is it sexist to say
men and women are different
is it sexist to say men and women aren't
different is what does that even mean
then you're telling me it should be
banned BBC Journal says well no not not
exactly not saying anything I'm just
curious I'm trying to say what you mean
by hateful content I'm asking for
specific examples
um and if and you just said that if
something is slightly sexist
that's hateful content does that mean
that it should be bad well you've asked
me you've asked me whether my feed
whether it's got less or more I'd say
it's got slightly more that's why I'm
asking for examples can I can you name
one example okay this is this is a key
so Elon Musk Begins by asking really for
just more of a definition of what the
guy's talking about but then the guy
brings up his own experience so the BBC
guy can't give a better definition or a
better description
because he's just parroting mindlessly
the establishment talking point beep
boop Twitter more hateful
South African man bad
so awful what they do today Elon Musk
one of the most prominent African
Americans in the world and these racist
whites they just attack him
the point for another time so Elon says
okay well
now that you've brought your own Twitter
feed into this forget about giving me a
better description
give me a concrete example of what
you're talking about because Elon is is
inferring here he's suspecting that hold
on this guy he's starting to change his
story a little bit I'm going to press
even harder honestly don't you I I
honestly I can't name a single example
I'll tell you why because I don't
actually use that for you feed anymore
because I just don't particularly like
it a lot of people a lot of people are
quite similar I I only I only look you
said you've seen more hateful content
hold on now there it is now now elon's
got him so he says what describe hateful
content well you know if it's a little
bit like this or that this or that
can you
can you go further well I've just
noticed in my own feed you know it's my
Twitter feed is much more hateful
oh okay well what's what's a concrete
example of that well actually I don't
really use my Twitter feed so now elon's
got him because now he's just caught
this guy in a lie the LIE is I've
noticed that my Twitter feed has gotten
more hateful
is this okay show me an example oh I
actually don't use my Twitter feed oh so
now I can't trust a word that you're
saying and one of the keys that allowed
Elon to suspect that that's what's going
on here is that the the BBC guy was
talking in very vague terms and he was
always hedging his bets oh it's slightly
sexist oh it's a little more hateful
well I'm just kind of noticed okay
that's a sign you have no idea what
you're talking about and on top of that
you're a liar so now Elon just destroys
this guy with facts and logic a single
example not even one I'm not sure I've
used that fee for the last
because I've been I've been using I've
been using Twitter since you've taken
over for the last six months okay so
then you must have at some point seen
that you're for you hateful content I'm
asking for one example right you can't
give a simple one and I'm saying I say
so that you don't know what you're
talking about really yes because you
can't be a single example of hateful
content not even one tweet and yet
you're claimed that the hateful content
was high well that's a false no what I
create a slide what no no what I claim
was uh there are many uh organizations
that say that that kind of information
is on the rise now whether whether it
has them
again there it is that now is changed
his story again
so Elon just asks a very basic question
how have you seen an uptick in hateful
content if you haven't seen anything in
your Twitter feed well no I just know
because I used it before yeah you used
it before you're alleging an uptick in
hateful content
and you by the way you can't even give
me one example from that period of time
so what are you talking about and then
once you do he changes the story again
he said no well I've just
I've just read reports you know from
these liberal
from these other liberal sources and
that the reports say it so I'm just I'm
going to restate that as fact and I'm
going to lie and pretend it's been my
own experience but yeah it's from
Liberal Outlets that hate you
he goes on someone like this the
Strategic dialogue Institute in the U in
the UK they will say that so people will
say all sorts of nonsense I'm literally
asking for a single example and you
can't name one right and as people will
say all sorts of nonsense
this this BBC guy I think he's being
sincere in his disregard for the truth I
think he comes by that honestly he comes
by his dishonestly honestly he thinks
well that's just no that's just how all
people talk we just recite the liberal
talking points I Didn't Do It
consciously I just that's just what I do
and then
I well no I but it everybody's saying it
it's the that's what the outlets are
that's what beep it's like it's like
Elon broke his brain
and and what does Elon say he says yeah
well people say all sorts of nonsense
so like when when now that I'm on the
road I'm going to these college campuses
when I talk to a young liberal
especially on an issue like
transgenderism which is so manifestly
absurd but which the liberal
establishment has doubled and tripled
and quadrupled down on
the look at me
with this pitiful stare they'll look at
me and they won't have anything to say
because they'll all they'll be able to
say is but
I was told this was true I but everybody
everybody says this is true that men can
be women
the answer to which is exactly what Elon
said here yeah people say all sorts of
nonsense
it doesn't make it true how is it true
give me any example and the poor BBC guy
you all he's a liar but you you almost
feel for him because he's just he's
squirming
trying to dig himself out of this hole
of lies that he stood for himself use
that fate but how did you know that I
don't think this is getting anything you
literally said you experienced more
hateful content and then couldn't name a
single example right and as I said
that's absurd I haven't I haven't
actually looked at that feed but how
would you know this beautiful content
because I'm saying that's what I saw a
few weeks ago I can't give you an exact
example let's move on we have we only
have a certain amount of time
um well
yeah let's move on that's that's
probably your best bet I haven't
actually seen it but no I did see it but
I didn't but I read a report and I heard
it from a person and anyway let's move
on and elon's response is just perfect
wow
Elon Musk is more intelligent than
most people in public life
probably pretty much anybody in public
life he's he's up there okay but Elon
Musk talks in really plain terms
that is a sign of intelligence
and what the a lot of people are loath
to do that because a lot of
conservatives feel intimidated by the
Liberals the Liberals will use all these
fancy words all this academic jargon
they've got all their studies oh we have
our studies that can show you absurd
things that we know are not true and so
a lot of people don't want to speak in
plain language
the smartest people throughout all of
history
have by and large spoken in really plain
language Plato writes in a way that is
clear and concise and could be
understood by a 15 year old just as much
as by a 50 year old
it's it's the people who use all sorts
of silly jargon and who try to dance
around facts and coin all these
neologisms those are the people
who you've got to watch out for and so
when Elon Musk speaks in these plain
terms that
that's how we all want to speak
why is
why is transgenderism wrong
because men can't be women but you don't
even know even understand
[Applause]
even if I hadn't I don't need to read
some 20th century weirdo to know what we
all know to be true intuitively just
those plain words even that very end of
the very end of the interview wow
yeah wow
now despite the lackluster economy
actually maybe because of the lackluster
economy the daily wire is thriving not
only that we are hiring we're currently
looking for a video editor to join our
fast growing post-production team this
person will get the opportunity to work
on a variety of content including our
daily podcasts long form interviews
YouTube videos as well as shows like Ben
Shapiro's debunked documentaries from
Jordan Peterson and more four plus years
of professional video editing experience
and familiarity and working at a very
fast-paced environment with high turn
runtimes is required a link to your reel
is required for consideration the
position is based in Nashville Tennessee
for more information and to apply go to
dailywire.com careers that is
dailywire.com careers
you know I'm I'm pretty fascinated with
AI
even though I I am somewhat fearful that
demons are infecting Ai and I'm I'm not
to say fearful but I'm prepared for AI
to take my job as well as all of your
jobs and I do think it could lead us to
a techno dystopia in which the machines
just come around shooting us all but I'm
nevertheless fascinated by it we have
got a great
AI
challenge coming up from Mr Davies over
on the member block so much to get to so
much more I had to say today we'll get
to a little bit in the member block
we'll get to a lot more tomorrow and
we'll get to a little bit tonight at UW
Superior if you're not a member become
one at dailywire.com Knowles promo code
Knowles k-n-w-l-e-s get two months free
on all annual plans
see over at the member block
[Music]